[Music]
taylor swift is dropping a whole bunch
of them about her new music but is the
cover of her album reputation that seems
to have all signs pointing west
mark
[Music]
is taylor about to blast kim and kanye
on her new album don't
say i didn't say i didn't warn you the
swifties say yes and point to clues all
over taylor's just released cover art
first that medieval looking font check
this out taylor's typeface appears
almost identical to the style kanye used
for the merchandise for his life of
pablo tour
second the cover photo it's a bold new
look for taylor and the slicked back
hair sure looks like kim's style and by
the way the image was snapped by two of
kim's favorite photographers
and then there's tate's comfy oversized
sweater i mean it sure looks like
something that could be from kanye jeezy
fashion line there's also a possible kim
connection to taylor's instagram page
which is now dominated by this
threatening snake-like creature swift
was branded a snake online after her tip
with kim and kanye over his famous
lyrics i feel like me and taylor might
still have sex why i made that famous
kim posted this flood of snake emojis on
national snake day which seemed to be
intended for taylor we may know more
after taylor's new single drops late
tonight the music video is rumored to be
debuting at this sunday's mtv video
music awards life continues to be
inspiration and it's i think you have to
live a life in order to be inspired by
that life is there anybody that you
would not ever write about
no not really taylor will inspire you
but if you cross her look out
[Music]
you